[Music]
so oh one thing right at the start I'm
not here to sell you no ops or even
Google is your sre this is based on my
another's experience running services at
Google and with conversations with
longtime App Engine customers great
DevOps engineers or s Ari's if you
prefer provide a lot of leverage for
moving your engineering organization
forward with continuous delivery and
accelerating your ability to reliably
deliver changes if you don't have anyone
actively doing the DevOps role your most
experienced developers end up getting
pulled into the firefighting efforts
involved in running your system so one
way or another you're going to end up
doing ops and DevOps
well you may not do end up doing DevOps
you may end up just doing operations
we'll talk a little bit about the
difference in in a moment so every
software system that has customers is
going to need care and feeding and
maintenance and experience devoxx
practitioners understand how to do that
more efficiently so DevOps are great
I'm not saying throw them out the window
I'm not saying don't have them I'm
saying let's make them even better
common ratio for DevOps to feature
software engineers is something on the
order of five maybe ten to one for some
reasons that I'll talk about in this
talk
App Engine covers a lot of your DevOps
basics for free letting you spend more
time in your application that means your
DevOps engineers can get more stuff done
they can move your organization faster
or if you want your DevOps talent can
also spend some time improving your
application and writing feature code
rather than chasing around and putting
out fires and fixing your infrastructure
because your infrastructure will be
beautiful and sparkling I've spent nine
of the last twelve years on call at
Google half of that was in sre the other
half was as a developer supporting
systems that I'd written that were not
yet accepted by sre because they were
new and not critical enough if you went
to Ben trainers fireside chat earlier he
and Ben much
talked about how at Google sre teams
come in and focus on the services that
are already important and make them
better and it's not a given that you
have an SRE team at all that's a little
different in some organizations an app
engine incorporates a lot of the stuff
that I've learned about running reliable
services it's one of the things that
attracted me to working on App Engine
for scaling both to millions of queries
per second and running hundreds of
services with a single small team
switching app engine isn't gonna double
your productivity I don't think I could
promise you anything that would do that
but it can give you a measurable
improvement in how much time you spend
on feature development rather than on
the operations stuff that has to get
done since we're talking about spending
time on development I'm going to talk
first about why you might be spending a
lot of time on operations so Google s3
has a concept called toil and toil is
work that you do to need to do today if
it'll come back tomorrow and you'll have
to do it again it's not optional you
need it in order to keep your service
running
additionally toil doesn't necessarily
require a lot of judgment or creative
problem-solving but it has to be done
right or your system will be down or
broken or slow you might recognize some
some of these sorts of things as
maintenance operation procedures or
other best practices documents for
handling various issues that come up
with a service now mops can be a good
idea for operations that happen
infrequently like a manual database
failover if you do that once or twice a
year but if you're using the same mop
once or twice a week
that's probably Thailand you should be
looking at automating it rather than
just streamlining the work that people
do and the other the antidote to toil
like this is automation so if you can
recognize and understand what needs to
happen you can find ways to write
software that works around or solves the
problem so that humans can get back to
being creative thinking coding designing
listening to customers instead
of fighting your infrastructure now
there's a whole lot of data center
automation software out there already in
order to talk about what makes App
Engine so useful and special I'm gonna
start by talking about some of the other
options for data center automation
software so at the base of the stack we
have what I call fleet management
solutions these solutions are targeted
managing a fleet hundreds tens thousands
of individual heterogeneous servers
they're all different or there's enough
differences between them that you need
to pay attention to those differences
they may be running on physical Hardware
they may be running on virtual Hardware
it might be a mix oftentimes you're
assigning workloads to individual
servers statically a single server is
for a single workload and you don't
necessarily automatically scale or if
you automatically scale it's a little
bit of a manual process using something
like a managed instance group or I
forget what the Amazon equivalent is
load balance group there's a lot of code
in these fleet management tools for
rolling out and managing operating
system and library level patches because
every machine is set is different it has
its own kernel it has its own installed
libraries maybe some of them are red hat
maybe some of them are Debian maybe
you've got some sauce there or windows
and in addition to all of that it also
rolls out your application code and
manages it but that's just one of
several jobs that it's got to do now the
great thing about these things is
they're really adaptable they're really
flexible and they let you automate your
software deployments to your VMs and
your physical machines and with
integration work you can implement
health checking and monitoring repairs
and things like that so that's actually
pretty good in terms of replacing a lot
of your toilet the next level of
abstraction that you've probably heard
about a lot at this conference is
container orchestration so at this layer
of the stack you're using something like
kubernetes or meso s-- or docker
and you don't worry so much about
managing the base layer of operating
systems that's all unified and pretty
abstract and instead you're managing
resource provisioning by describing your
application in terms of resource
requirements it has how much RAM how
much CPU what network ports what storage
you need and then the orchestration
layer assigns those resources to
physical or virtual nodes automatically
and can perform failover and pooling and
resource grouping so resource assignment
container orchestration can be fairly
dynamic and can react to those failures
or the load changes by rebalancing the
cluster maybe even moving a workload
from one machine to another because
you've discovered that one machine is
overloaded which is great and introduces
a whole host of new things new needs
that you never realized you had a like
service discovery you need to keep track
of where everything's running and
clearer abstraction boundaries between
systems because you need to actually
deploy and scale them differently so
moving up in this stack
moving up in the stack this way frees
you from a lot of the OS patch
management and deployment toil because
you can describe things in a high-level
and can give you resource efficiency
games by bin packing multiple containers
onto the same physical node without
managing individual VMs and operating
systems additionally because resources
are aggregated in this way this can also
actually simplify your hardware
build-out because you can have a more
uniform fleet and have the software be
responsible for bin packing things onto
smaller machines as needed and so
containers are a great tool and
container orchestration definitely
simplifies packaging and resource
sharing but I'm here to talk about
another layer above that that removes
even more toil and gives you even more
efficiency benefits and take your
application management to the next level
so App Engine is one example of a
platform as a service platform service
is designed to understand and cater to a
particular type of application so you
can see here we've
App Engine and Heroku and Cloud Foundry
that are all in a similar business of
handling stateless Web Services but
things like lambda lambda and cloud
functions are another platform as a
service that's targeting a slightly
different market where web services
aren't really their core thing it's run
a little piece of code and spin up very
and down very quickly in this serverless
environment and then you can see data
flow as well is another platform for
handling your data processing you
wouldn't use it to serve a web
application but it's a great way to
organize your data management and you're
like ETL pipelines stateless Web
Services which is what I'm going to
focus on for the rest of the talk covers
a lot of ground from static or dynamic
websites to api's and shim api's which
can aggregate content from a number of
different backends and provide a
seamless content feed to mobile clients
or to other api consumers stateless Web
Services while they cover a lot of
ground they also have a lot of things in
common so that gives us the ability to
provide out-of-the-box experiences that
you'd have to do a lot of integration on
some of the lower layers to get so I'll
show you an example in just a moment of
what the full set up would look like but
there's a there's a recipe out there
that's pretty easy to find to scale an
application using those fleet management
solutions it involves Nagios monitoring
triggering chef to do a deployment based
on high CPU usage so you find your
Nagios instance you write you put some
stuff in there it has to coordinate with
some stuff that's in chef and you own
all those integration pieces App Engine
provides these as scaling knobs on your
application without needing to for you
to explicitly say hey here's my
monitoring rule and that means do this
in terms of deploying another
application note App Engine knows how to
do that because you're a stateless web
service and because your app is driven
by HTTP requests we can also give
you automatic latency and request load
monitoring we can also trace your log
statements back to the particular URL
handler and highlight problem areas in
your application these are some of the
tools that internally we build an SRE at
Google and by providing this platform as
a service we can build them for you in a
scalable way as opposed to a bunch of
one-off things for individual services
so this is an example of how you could
build your own comparable platform to
some of the stuff that I've talked about
that App Engine does there's actually a
few more things that I didn't feel like
putting in here because it's already a
lot of stuff around your application so
we'd start with your application you
start developing let's say you're using
Java and you're using jetty it's great
on your desktop but when you want to go
to production you'll need to set up auto
scaling and multiple copies of your
application and then you'll need to put
a load balancer in front like nginx and
then to debug your application you'll
set up the e lk stack so now you've got
elasticsearch and log stash and cabana
that you're running in addition to your
application and nginx
you can send a Geo's for monitoring so
now you've got some visibility into
what's going on and maybe Nagios is
monitoring your LK stack as well as
nginx in your application and you're
getting all these metrics and then you
discover that you're suddenly running 30
machines and so why don't we go and take
saltstack and use that to actually
organize and manage your rollouts
congratulations now you've got 31
machines and furthermore I've given you
one set of examples here why don't you
replace nginx with Envoy or there's a
bunch of different log solutions so when
you put all the combinations together
there's probably a hundred different
ways to build this same system is
everyone in your organization making the
same choices for these are you building
you know LK over here and you're using
Splunk over there standardizing on one
set of solutions makes it a lot easier
for people to move from one part of the
organization to another and understand
what tools are available
platform-as-a-service is one way of
standardizing those that set of tools so
that everyone has a common baseline that
they're working from and they don't need
to learn a new stack of systems when
they go to switch projects so assuming
that you're buying what I've got to say
so far and that you're interested in how
App Engine fits into this I'm gonna
explain a little bit about how App
Engine is organized before I dive into
some of the recipes and features you
don't need to know this stuff to start
using App Engine and I've met people who
spent years building monolithic
applications perfectly happy with App
Engine and don't necessarily understand
or worry about all of this stuff but if
you're looking to grow and organize a
team and scale out your team more
efficiently it can be useful to
understand how applications and services
and versions all fit together so App
Engine subdivides each project which is
an application which in App Engine we
call it the top level and application in
two independent services which can be
pushed and scaled separately so you can
think of services like micro services
they each do a separate thing your micro
services can be very small and have a
single URL your micro services can be
not so micro and can be your entire
application if you want each service in
turn is made up of a set of deployed
versions so you do a deployment and that
creates a new version and at the service
level you can choose to shift traffic
forward and backwards between versions
so one of the things that you're
deciding when you decide how to split
your service up into micro services or
split your application up into services
is which things should be pushed
together which things should be pushed
separately if you have three API
endpoints that I'll touch the same
database and need to use the same schema
maybe that's all one service if you have
another endpoint that only talks to
videos and and cloud storage maybe that
should be a separate service maybe you'd
rather have it all be bundled together
because that's easier for you to manage
in your CI system that's up to you
within each version App Engine
automatically creates creates and
destroys
census of each version in response to
load so every time you write code on App
Engine you're writing code for
horizontal scaling automatically and we
can expand one version to be running on
thousands of nodes or scale it down to
zero on standard or one on flow or one
on the flexible environment if it's not
receiving much traffic so moving on from
the high-level theory I'm going to show
you some examples of how App Engine lets
you run your services faster and
smoother and apply less DevOps effort to
keeping everything running some of you
may have seen this before if you're into
sre type topics
this is Dickerson's hierarchy of
reliability reliability is one of the
main goals of DevOps reliability of
delivery reliability of the service in
terms of uptime reliability of process
in making sure that things are
repeatable and this hierarchy was
proposed by Mikey Dickerson who was the
architect of the healthcare.gov rescue
and a former Googler sorry I actually
worked with Mikey and adds essary and
this formulation based on his experience
makes a lot of sense to me and it's
based on Maslow's hierarchy of needs if
you're a psychology person if you
haven't seen his talk in health care of
its there's several versions on YouTube
and it's really interesting to hear how
he was able to go into a very broken
system and find ways to bring that up
the hierarchy and introduce stability
and reliability into the whole process
and it's a great essary story App Engine
can help reduce the amount of effort for
getting all of these things but I'm
going to particularly focus on the ones
I've highlighted in blue I realized
that's a lot of them but I thought that
more in depth would be a little better
than covering post-mortems in
development so for each of these layers
I'm going to be showing you both the
built-in functionality and some
additional things that you can do to
take them to the next level and be more
efficient
than just the tools that we ship you so
starting with monitoring I mentioned
earlier App Engine is a platform
as-a-service
so we already have top level metrics on
your application request latency
requests per second queue times number
of instances and all of that sort of
thing can be tracked both across the
application as a whole and we can
actually also track things like latency
and request times on specific URLs if
you're interested and the best part is
you don't need to add explicit
instrumentation into your code since we
are offering you the load balancer we
can integrate all that monitoring into
the load balancing layer and we
integrate that with stack driver
monitoring and inspection so you can
also export specific application metrics
directly from your code and align them
with the same metrics that are coming
from your load balancer if you don't
want a direct monitoring dependency in
your code you're worried about either
the latency or the stability you can
configure stack driver to export custom
metrics from your logs and those can be
aligned with your with a automatically
collected instance data this allows you
to create a simple single timeline with
business metrics like conversion rate
and code changes such as latency
improvements you can then use this fact
driver api's to aggregate and export the
data and run regression analysis to
figure out things like the effect of
latency on conversion rates so putting
all your data in one place and giving
you powerful API is to extract it let
you pull out more value than you might
if you were putting everything
separately and you had some things in
Nagios and some things later on in your
ETL pipeline speaking of things like ETL
pipelines though the stature of our
logging api is really handy for digging
into issues the log viewer is good for
getting a quick view into what's going
on but exporting logs into bigquery is
amazing how many of you have used
bigquery before you might know what I'm
talking about
so I can use sequel queries like this to
dig in and associate error messages with
specific
URLs for a specific customer even if I'm
getting hundreds or thousands of
requests per second you know and I have
half a million customers you know I have
I have this one customer issue and they
say you know this stuff all seems to be
wonky but replies are particularly bad
so I can dig in and find out that's true
but they're not doing very many replies
I can also potentially dig in and get
the stack traces I can get any other
info or warning error messages and you
can really pull out a lot of data by
putting things in sequel and then
throwing bigquery or putting things in
bigquery and then using sequel to
extract out the information you really
need as an additional monitoring tool
stackdriver trace is pretty cool for
investigating the calls made by a
particular request or your back-end
connections and it's automatically
enabled on standard so you can just try
it out and see what it tells you and on
flex or on-premise there's a library
that you can link in that will give you
the same information and I believe it
also integrates with some open source
tracing tools don't remember the name
so incident response everyone's favorite
favorite thing to do but when things go
wrong
you really want to get things back
working ASAP you you've got that
visceral my customers are angry at me
feeling as necessary I had to write a
lot of post mortems that basically
concluded rollback would have fixed this
hours earlier than pushing new code so
by now my first instinct whenever I get
a page and I am on call not right now
but for the app engine management API I
am on that on-call rotation my first
impact is my first instinct is to find
what changed and roll it back even if I
don't see any correlation and see if
things get better while I go and dig in
further so App Engine because we have
those multiple deployed versions gives
you a quick way to roll back to earlier
versions it's a single action it takes
less than ten seconds to do and there's
also an audit log so you can see what's
actually been changed recently which
gives you
helps you figure out which thing you
should roll back so as I mentioned my
team actually builds the management
api's and we talked when we were
building the traffic splitting controls
about building an app that just lets you
roll back and you can see that my UX
skills are probably not the ones you'd
want building this so fortunately we
have a cloud console mobile app that
already lets you do this so don't worry
you won't have to suffer through my UI
now obviously rollback is not going to
fix everything
and there's some failures that App
Engine will never fix for you but if you
look at post-mortems in your
organization you'll probably find
something similar to Google which is
that code and configuration pushes are
one of the largest sources of outages it
makes sense you're deliberately changing
something you think you know what you're
doing well you know what you were doing
90% of the time when the other 10%
doesn't go so well but you tested the
common happy case so rollback solves
those problems it doesn't solve back-end
services down it doesn't solve user data
corruption rollback sometimes will help
you there by changing your query back
pattern back to what it was before or
not corrupting any more user data but
you'll still have to fix those yourself
and it's still up to you to make the
decisions as to when to rollback and how
to use the tools to fix things and if
you're using App Engine consistently the
other benefit is that all your tools
look the same and so your most
experienced people from one project can
help out with another project when
everything's on fire
so outages not so much fun pushing code
seeing your code go live a lot more fun
so test and release much better incident
management got into the incident
response or you don't have any customers
but App Engine also has a lot of tools
for testing and releases and the
multiple versions is the start of that
but not the end of the story
so you can see here in the production
environment we're doing a traffic shift
from our current release to the next
release and we're canarian it with 10%
of traffic so we've got some confidence
that doesn't break everything but we're
not putting all our users at risk yet so
if something goes bad for 1% of our
users on the new version it's actually a
point one percent outage at that moment
so I've still got three nines it's not
too bad
additionally you can see that we have a
test environment that has a whole bunch
of other versions running so everybody
can have their own version for
development which my experience has been
drastically accelerates things versus
hot seating on one pre production
environment so what what does App Engine
not cover for testing and release well
you'll still need to run your own tests
you'll need to write them yourself and
you still need a your own CI system and
starting them you need to choose your
source release and start the deployment
yourself App Engine has integrations
with tools like Jenkins Travis and
circle CI there's a lot of other systems
out there a lot of them do have app
engine integrations and I've actually
built my own little toy CI system at one
point just to play around at the
management API and most of my time was
spent figuring out how to package up my
code upload it to cloud storage and then
the actual API call at the end is pretty
simple so if you're thinking about
building your own it's not too scary
there's some work you need to do but
it's not too scary it's also easy to
deploy the same code you can see here to
the test environment as to production
with a slightly different configuration
I know I've seen a couple different
patterns for doing this one common one
is to have a set of settings in
datastore or cloud storage or or
potentially even cloud sequel where you
connect to an address that's based on
your instance name or your app name or
something like that which tells you
where to find everything else the other
pattern which I slightly prefer is to
actually define your configuration
settings in code and use a configuration
class which you select which one of
these to use
and the benefit of that is that all your
configuration changes end up in source
control automatically you don't wonder
hey who changed this data store setting
or you know how did this config file get
uploaded to GCS so I'm going to show you
an example of how that works so you can
see here I define a base configuration
class that could be development
environment settings that could just be
you know just in this case it's none if
you're using a base config you are
probably doing it wrong you should be
getting one of the other ones and it
makes it more obvious when something
goes wrong then you can see I defined a
production configuration and then this
magic config basically chooses one of
the other configuration classes and
extracts values from it if there isn't
an overriding environment variable
setting and then you can see my
top-level config object is an eval that
picks one of these classes and defaults
to development so that if someone
forgets to actually define the
environment variable they don't start
running against production referencing
this and source control you can get code
reviews on when you're doing it you can
you can actually test your values and
make sure that you don't end up with
conflicting values as your configuration
gets more complex and also when you make
can make configuration changes you can
roll them out with traffic splitting the
same way that you roll out your code
changes adding a new back-end
maybe you type at it wrong it's good to
have that be a sort of a slow process
rather than a big bang switchover so so
far we talked about the basics of app
development but now that we've talked
about keeping your head above water
capacity planning is one of those things
that you always sort of want to get to
in the future but App Engine actually
lets you get to it never and that's okay
because App Engine has automatic scaling
it will scale down to zero and it will
scale out to thousands of instances
automatically and you don't need to do
capacity planning and reservations and
decide do I gonna need this capacity for
year or three years or even do I need to
request a quota increase app engine can
automatically scale for spikey events
with low latency past past 20000 QPS and
four small spikes where small is
somewhat relative you don't even need to
contact Google if you're thinking about
launching the next Pokemon go we might
like a heads up but if you're not
watching Pokemon go and you're launching
something that's just going a little bit
viral then shouldn't need to talk to
Google at all so as I mentioned the
standard runtime support scale to zero
which makes standard runtimes great for
keeping around development tools and
dashboards and stuff that's not used all
the time but every so often you want to
be able to pull it out and you want it
to be running immediately standard is
also much faster for deployment than
flex so if you're trying to iterate on
your development cycle you may find that
deploying the standard is faster the
Flex environment requires a VM to be
running in order to collect all of the
metrics needed for scaling and for
scaling and to determine how much load
and so forth is going on but you can
stop the versions that you're not using
and stop getting built for them so we
have a lot of customers who are using
App Engine with things like data store
or BigTable whoo scale out very wide on
their App Engine side and if you're
using something that Cloud sequel you'll
have to provision your cloud sequel
instances so if you can use a
horizontally scalable system for your
storage you might not have to do any
capacity planning at all stuff to do
budget planning I've run some demos
where I wish I'd done budget planning
beforehand so the cloud console which
you can see here and the stack driver UI
which I'll show you later cover a lot of
the basic user experience for managing
your app and another thing to note is
the cloud console is building on
Google's public API so
you can also extract all this data to
your own consoles if you're building
your own view of the world
so before I talked in more detail I
wanted to highlight a couple of the cool
things we've got built in on the left
hand side you can see the cloud trace
suggestions it's automatically
identified several several issues with
datastore you probably can't see it here
but it says use of offset in datastore
queries which is an anti-pattern because
when you use an offset datastore still
has to read through the first things it
just throws them away to hand you the
next stuff used query cursors instead
many successive datastore put and get
calls so by doing these separately my
app is paying a latency penalty each
time I do a put or I get whereas if I
did multiple at the same time or
parallelized them I would have much
lower latency overall because we
understand your architecture and how
your back-end our pcs relate to your
your front-end URL requests we can
actually determine that things like the
consecutive put and get calls are coming
from the same handler as opposed to
different handlers that happen to have
similar timing and so we can suggest
these sorts of improvements on the right
hand side you can see the error
reporting has picked up a bunch of 500s
that we've served to customers over the
last day and highlighted particular
issues that we should probably be
looking at and fixing again this is
stuff that we've automatically built in
so you could obviously run this stuff
yourself and go through the logs
yourself but we've already given you a
basic version that will often meet your
needs but sometimes you know your
workflow better than what we do and so
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
you can make an even better UX for your
team that maybe isn't the same as the
you excellent the next team would build
so with all these api's there's lots of
great ways that you can integrate them
together some of them mostly using cloud
platform technologies some of them using
just a few but using some common
patterns
to make it easier to debug production so
and the other thing is of course if you
find these useful do them if you don't
if that sounds like a terrible idea to
you there's nothing that says everyone
must do things the same way in
production your team should be
consistent but you don't have to be
consistent with the next with the team
in another company so for us we have a
mailing list where we send push
announcements and status updates about
production in our push instructions we
used to have a line that said send me on
the mailing list about the push there's
two problems with this the first one is
that the instruction didn't actually
tell you what to say
so every person had to interpret that
individually and the second one was that
a person had to do this and it wasn't
just a robot automatically sending
something like a summary or hey just
pushes started so a lot of you probably
use slack or IRC rather than email for
keeping a track of what's going on in
production you can automatically update
slack when their production changes such
as traffic splits version deployments or
permission changes by setting up a logs
filter on the audit log and using that
to publish just those audit logs to
pub/sub so you can say just users added
to a Akal or just traffic splits or new
versions and traffic splits but don't
tell me about deleting versions and
cloud functions can pull things off of
that queue and automatically update a
slack topic telling you everything
that's going on in production did you
care about it and then all the rest of
the stuff you don't have to go and look
at the audit log it's already in the
tool that you're already looking at
every day you probably also track which
commits fix a particular issue but if
you've run production systems for a
while
there's a difference between the fix is
committed to source control and the fix
is actually running in production it's a
very important distinction and sometimes
when you have to rollback you want to
know what's gonna break when I roll
so if you have a consistent way of
tracking which CLS are going into a
particular release and naming your
releases in a way that's coherent you
can update your JIRA or whatever using
for issue tracking to indicate which
things will be broken when you roll back
to a particular version and so your
rollback is great but sometimes there's
a bad thing that will happen at the same
time so you need to do some mitigating
steps or something like that and this
gives you some operational awareness of
exactly what's going on and this last
integration is a really cool one that
I've seen some teams build at Google but
everyone seems to have to build their
own solution and a lot of this is
because what makes it release really bad
is not Universal for some people error
rate increase for some people it's
latency there you may have other metrics
but you can have a staff driver alert if
you assume you can describe what makes a
bad release you can have a stack driver
alert that detects that there's a
problem like an error rate increase and
sends a webhook or an SMS notification
to your control stack to automatically
rollback that release before a human
even has to get involved you may still
want to tell a human that this is
happening and you may even want to page
them and if you're building such a
system you probably also want a Deadman
switch so that you're not fighting the
automation if the release really needs
to go out or you really need to make
some other changes so I've talked a
whole bunch of talk about ways that you
can make things more more efficient now
I'm gonna do a demo because my
understanding is that demos are part of
the reason that people come and watch
this stuff see whether demo bursts into
flames or not so I'm gonna show how you
can take off the shelf software not
designed for App Engine and run it on
App Engine and get some of those App
Engine benefits in particular I'm going
to use JIRA which is a closed source
issue and project tracker typically you
run it on a singleton VM
and since its close source I really nope
don't okay you can cut over now but I
still have a little bit more to talk
about before
definitely don't cut ever now I actually
have a couple more slides too so I can't
really make it any software changes to
make it to to the JIRA software itself
to make it run better on App Engine
I do use the Flex environment here but I
thought that it would be interesting to
show you a real application being put on
App Engine that wasn't designed that way
and JIRA seemed like hey this is
something that probably a lot of you
have seen or use so my architecture
looks pretty simple my developers talk
to JIRA running it on App Engine I'm
using cloud sequel as the backend
database because I don't I'm doing this
to not manage servers so I'm not gonna
set up my own server my own Oracle or
Postgres or something like that I'm
gonna use what Google has and I'm gonna
have I'm using flex because I'm gonna
need to run a little additional code
inside the docker container that's not
the main web application process and one
of the great things about the Flex
environment if you're trying to do
something like this is that in addition
to Java and node in PHP and all those
other lovely runtimes flex can run raw
docker containers so I start with a
container that's built on the Google
Java Runtime and then I do a bunch of
work to install JIRA and the my sequel
connector and so forth I set it to be on
the correct port and then you can see
that I copy in a wrapper script that
does all the fixes I need and a core
database config although that wrapper
actually takes an environment variable
and puts it into the DB config at
runtime so that I can change which cloud
sequel instance I'm talking to so one
interesting feature of JIRA is that it's
got this database for all your issues
but it actually also built a local on
disk Lucena index in order to be able to
search all of them so that's kind of
big stateful local cash and we're
talking about stateless Web Services
fortunately JIRA has a rien dexing API
so I can use that to at startup and
periodically after that reindex my
database in order to get JIRA to
actually have search working and do
things like which issues are assigned to
me actually shows up I also use basic
scaling or manual scaling to keep
exactly one instance running per version
so that there's less chance of updates
going to one server and then needing to
call reindex on another if you were
scaling out into your really large that
might be a problem most of the time this
if you're getting 5 QP s to your JIRA
instance something's probably wrong so
now if you could switch over so I'm
running this off of my Chromebook since
that's my primary development machine
but this means that I need some place
for I can run the raw VM commands so my
typical pattern is to spin up a worker
vm in the project that I'm using and it
makes it really easy to install tools
for demos and things like that it also
means that I won't have any fancy pretty
editors and instead I'll be mostly using
tools like VI and less ok here we go
we have SSH let's see can everyone read
that great ok so before this talk I
actually built a new JIRA image based on
the fresh out of the oven latest 732
release from March first it was great
that they shipped a release because that
meant that I wasn't just installing the
same software again because I started
working on this demo long before they
shipped it so you can see in the
container registry I have a base image
and a JIRA 732 image
now I'm going to go back and here is my
command - I'll tell you a little bit
about what this is doing I don't need
help either so I'm deploying a version
named 732 based on this JIRA image and
an app dot llamo that I have in the same
directory the app DML little oops so I
say it's a custom run it's a custom run
time running on flex I give it a
instance tag just in case I needed
special firewall rules it turns out I
don't I assign two CPUs and two gigs of
ram I turn off health checks because
JIRA doesn't know to answer 200 at the
app engine health check URL so I just
say don't worry about that and I have
stack driver monitoring do that instead
and you can see at the bottom I've set
manuals manual scaling to one instance
so that I don't end up with multiple
copies each with their own big fat local
cache the last two flags say whatever
versions running now don't stop that the
default for flex to save money and
confusion is that your old versions are
shut down and your new when you deploy a
new version so that you don't end up
paying for you know half dozen of VMs as
you're developing the know promote flag
says I'm deploying this new version but
please don't make it live yet I'll show
you later on in the demo how we make it
live obviously if you don't say no
promote we could just have it happen as
soon as it's ready so as I mentioned the
Flex environment can take a few minutes
to start the VMS configure the load
balancing and so forth and your also
takes a few minutes to start from a
fresh install so while that's happening
I'm going to show you I'm gonna say yes
because otherwise we would not get any
further and now I am going to show you
what we have running so you can see
we've got Jerry it looks pretty normal
if I log in you
can see oh look I've got a bunch of
issues assigned to me which is how I'm
gonna keep track of what stuff I'm
supposed to show you so we're going to
start by showing off the log explore
some of you've probably already seen
this and so by default so this is from
the last time I ran it by default this
will show you the standard out and stare
standard error plus the nginx server
that's in front of your application but
you can also pull in things like vm
events or the syslog from the vm and
let's get the whole pile of stuff yeah
you can see that we just have a new
audit log event here that says that we
are starting the operation will tell us
that the operation ID and then in the
reefs in the proto payload it will tell
you this is an audit log and that this
is called by service data just down off
the pot on the screen this was a create
version request and here is all the
information about the version so you can
see it's flex it's running on the VM
manual scaling and some other stuff that
we set here's our environment variable
so let's go back and ok so we've talked
a little bit about the logs Explorer so
the next thing I'm going to talk about
is how to add log metrics for data so
we've got this reindex or reenact singh
piece that i'm doing
let's take a look and
how we can actually keep track of how
often we're calling re-indexed and is
that working the way we expect so this
is the log based metric section of
stackdriver you can see it's right next
to the log Explorer or the log viewer
and in both cases you can use this
create metric link to create a new
metric that matches a pattern on your
application and this is the currently
running version and you can see there's
a lot of well here's a kernel message
from the kernel that's booting up but
there's also a lot of health checks and
some docker information and stuff like
that so I'm actually going to show you
the I've already created this metric and
you can see if we go in and edit it that
it's actually a query against the logs
API you can use this same type of query
to export stuff to bigquery or to
pub/sub and you can see that here we're
looking at standard out and standard
error for a message that says
re-indexing is 100% complete and we have
a bunch of these messages from 9 p.m.
and from last night when I was working
on it so so that's how you set up these
metrics let's take a little take a look
at what you can do with them after
you've set them out so I've added them
to the stack driver dashboard and
there's no data over the last 1 hour but
if we look over the last day we can see
that I started some PM's and they did
reindex this at that time you can also
see the request rate and that I was
messing around a bunch with the JR
instance earlier today and that at one
point the latency was really high but
all the rest of the time it was low and
here's our CPU usage and it looks like
we're really not using two CPUs and
probably one would have been sufficient
so we figured out a little bit about how
to use log metrics and now I'm going to
talk about the two different interfaces
that you've got for looking at how your
app works so one of them is the standard
cloud console
so one of them is the standard cloud
console where you can see the basic
graphs and there's a pulldown where you
can see information for a particular
version and then things like CPU and
utilization and latency and so forth the
other option is to build a stack driver
custom dashboard the advantage of the
custom dashboards is that you can put
together lots of your data into one
place and you can put together different
dashboards for specific issues so maybe
sometimes you have CPU usage go crazy
maybe you're exporting the number of
back-end database connections and that
goes wild you can have different
dashboards for different purposes so
let's see how that deployment is going
so the deployment is finished I'm going
to go back over to JIRA and you can see
that right now
we are running 731 so if we close if we
go over to App Engine and look at the
versions that are available we have 731
or we have 732 we have one called base
and let's not use this one called bad
I'm going to this is an old habit the
migrated traffic button is actually a
better choice but I'm going to send a
hundred percent of the traffic to the
new new instance if this was a public
site I'd probably start at five or ten
percent this is an internal tool so I'm
just going to swing all the traffic over
to the new site and now let's see what
happens if we I don't know how much this
gives cash so we're going to reload the
page and it's gonna ask me to log in
again because it's a new jura instance
and it has a different cookie cache and
the last pass is not going to help me
and so you can see we're back on the
same page we were before but now we are
running seven three two so that's the
end of my demo and when you're ready you
can switch back to the other that's the
end of my talk
[Music]
[Music]